[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais toi là parce que j'ai vu un truc ce
week-end je voulais le faire et je
voulais le montrer au téléspectateur il
ya un nouveau jeu fait un carton c'est
que je lance comme ça des balles de ping
pong sur dix comme ça il faut mettre la
tête et met dans le vent le bayer
d'accor asie
[Applaudissements]
c'est là
aujourd'hui demain et après demain je
suis pas là parce que je suis en grand
parc engrand parents ça veut dire tu ai
pas envie d ces deux jours pour me
recentrer sur moi même on prend les
grandes décisions
elle est avec nous ce soir cristina
cordula destine à ma chérie tu parles
nous un petit peu des looks autour de la
table à chaque fois que tu viens j'aime
d'affaires un petit point dit la vérité
linden méthanier os x et puis c'est
efficace tout bleu marine c'est plus
chic mais bon le noir aussi sébastien
bleu nuit avec la petite pochette c'est
bien la petite chemise c'est bien chez
les couleurs du village
sur la terre elle avait quoi le
mannequin et assure la redoute qu'il est
vraiment il a tenu alors vous mettez je
voudrais le tee shirt jaune avec way
maman prévoit également la souvine je
lève je pense qu'on pouvait mieux faire
j'aime bien le côté super position mais
c'est peut-être la couleur de tichri que
des magistrats etc ou des gaules ait dit
la vérité
la gérer
[Musique]
alors on va voir le relooking déjà que
tu nous as fait il à belmont haut niveau
ce qui répond isabelle morini bosc et
raymond c'était ça regardez c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais patrick dupuis mais si ce local go
films primés de 7 à rio et non là c'est
les juges trouvent les yeux fermés
tu m'as bien qu'il ait pas de toute
façon tu peux pas de visée tu ne le vois
pas la séquence fait alors quel est
votre question largement défloré oui vu
le mal venait à me caser il faut passer
à la mairie
benjamin j'ai vu le mal que j'ai à me
caser ça me fait très peur
j'hésite énormément plus c'est vrai
qu'on est médiatisé donc je me dis est
ce que c'est la bonne occasion venez pas
d'ombré michael jackson
bien sûr il médiatisé j'ai pas dit ça
donc est-ce que je dois me résoudre ce
serait elle un peu la dernière chance
pour moi mais ce que je dois me résoudre
à m'inscrire sur un site de rencontres
j'y connais rien ça me fait peur donc
j'ai besoin de votre avis à tout ça
d'accord qui pensent que c'est une bonne
idée
ah oui je sais que ça fasse sérieuses et
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fin de gourmandes derrière des
débrouillards cherche un homme costaud
évolué avec de l'humour et de la
tendresse oui ou non je peux essayer
vous allez vous quel serait votre pseudo
sur un site libertin tigresse marenger
voulez-vous décevant mais je n'aurais
jamais sur un site ebay rabon mais si je
vois vos soins s'il ya un moyen pour
créer son pseudo le nom de son premier
animal de compagnie et son deuxième set
pour notre égard alors ça c'est ce que
je vous explique
ça c'est la technique en fait c'est la
technique des acteurs pornos et donc la
journée mondiale journée mondiale de la
paix sociale acoss et aux laboratoires
ce soir plus de la moitié de vos
chroniqueurs dormait sur le plateau du
coup à se coucher à 19h07 que ce soir on
va vivre la même le même enfer dites moi
ça très vite je suis là deux doigts de
mettre la supposée c'est signé le hic
rooney cher maxime vous écris une lettre
que je vais vous lire car l'enjeu est de
taille
personne ne vous écris jamais maxime
vous n'avez pas d'amis mais plus grave
encore vous n'avez point d' ennemi ni
lettre d'amour ni lettre d'injures
maxime vous suscité l'indifférence quand
vous donnez les audiences elles sont
fausses personne ne vous écoute
mais c'est fini cher maxime c'est fini
car je vous prend par la main et par
cette missive
mais là je vous prends souvent mail je
vous déclare mon amitié inaltérable et
je vous invite les 4 et 5 janvier 2020
un stage de dépucelage alors lancé il
croit au mariage de gilles mais dans mes
bras détail qui compte d'un mariage de
gilles on va voir si les gens croient ou
non à leur histoire
moi je vous dis franchement je n'y crois
plus mais moi je préfère me marier une
fois bien que trois ou quatre fois match
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là mon village l'album de
bilal kingdom est bien sûr y'a roi et à
la ceni singulier on va parler du livre
parce que je veux dire c'est pas un
livre prétexte le livre de bilal de
l'avis de tout le monde d'ailleurs c'est
aux éditions plon
c'est pas aux éditions voilà way you lie
ça s'est passé pas chez nous la course
et on résume est sûre dans le filet il
va être sur le figaro il arrive à être
dans le groupe m6 et il va être sur ses
douces et beaucoup ok voilà c'est quand
même c'est quand même beaucoup
voilà qu'à part une fois chez ruquier où
je les ai vus vraiment perdre le débat
c'est extrêmement rare c'est un
excellent débatteur et le problème c'est
qu'il faut éviter mais ont trouvé des
gens en face est là et là où je rejoins
eric c'est que moi je veux bien y aller
c'est vrai ouais
là
pour voir un coach déco en face d'eric
zemmour et pmp c'est une famille et je
crois que vous en avez la preuve vous
qui bio sur journée la preuve une belle
grande famille soudée où tout le monde
s'aime
et oui quand sincérité amour et quelques
piques au tour rim et bien c'est la tp
family alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
mathieu si c'est pas moi je l'en comme
une battante
tu vas tu as we dégueulasse mais celle
boucle quand eugène il était beau
avec l'âge comme beaucoup d'hommes
malheureusement j'ai pris de
l'embonpoint et j'ai pris l'oeuf ne voit
donc pas malheureusement j'habite pas
clermont ferrand mais c'est de ne pas le
montrer
je sais que benjamin castaldi a déjà
fait une liposuccion alors merci qui